[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
ici à strasbourg pour un nouveau numéro
d' europe hebdo
au sommaire cette semaine les questions
budgétaires avec la france tout d'abord
qui passe au prélèvement à la source au
1er janvier alors que tous les pays
européens l'utilisent déjà
nous en parlerons avec nos invités jean
arthuis eurodéputés français et mercedes
bresso
l'eurodéputée italienne nous débattront
également du budget de l'italie qui
tourne le dos à l'orthodoxie européenne
met tout de suite on parle du brésil
l'horloge tourne le breakbeat c'est dans
six mois le 29 mars la grande bretagne
et l'union européenne ne sont toujours
pas d'accord sur les conditions du
divorce chez les conservateurs comme
chez les travaillistes on se déchire sur
la stratégie à adopter
regardez
[Musique]
comment sortir de l'europe
deux ans après le oui au brésil les
conservateurs au pouvoir à londres
cherche toujours la meilleure façon de
quitter l'union en fin septembre les
dirigeants européens ont rejeté le plan
de theresa may au congrès annuel des
conservateurs cette semaine le ministre
du breakbeat met la pression sur
bruxelles
l' approche théologique de l'union
européenne ne laisse aucune place à un
compromis sérieux et pourtant on attend
de nous que nous mettions de côté
l'intégrité territoriale de notre propre
pays
si l'union européenne veut un accord
elle va être sérieuse et elle doit
l'être maintenant
londres doit présenter de nouvelles
propositions au sommet européen le 18
octobre mais theresa may a du mal à
trouver la bonne recette
son plan initial rejetée par l'union
européenne est aussi très contesté au
sein de son propre parti
la première ministre propose de garder
des relations commerciales étroites avec
l'union avec une réglementation commune
une proposition que les militants
conservateurs soutiennent sans
enthousiasme conséquence les partisans
d'une rupture nette avec bruxelles tente
de reprendre la main
boris johnson le principal rival interne
theresa may conteste son plan les fameux
plans checkers
ce mardi il a renouvelé ses attaques
c'est le moment de le faire et nous
avons le temps c'est le moment de jeter
shaker à la poubelle pratique ce n'est
pas pragmatique
ce n'est pas un compromis c'est
dangereux et instable politiquement
économiquement et mes chers collègues
conservateurs
ce n'est pas la démocratie ce n'est pas
ce pourquoi nous avons voté
[Musique]
le président divise aussi le parti
travailliste ne principal parti
d'opposition comme les négociations
piétinent
certains militants du lait beurre
réclament un nouveau référendum fin
septembre cinq mille personnes ont
manifesté en marge du congrès les
travailler ils disent carrément à la
direction du labour party
écoutez nous entende et nous donnez nous
un vote populaire
il est temps d'écouter les 1 million 400
mille électeurs du labour qui veulent à
présent resté et les deux millions de
jeunes qui sont maintenant en mesure de
voter pour leur propre avenir
mais le patron du leiber l'eurosceptique
jérémy corps been n'est pas favorable à
un nouveau référendum
il veut se poser en recours si theresa
may ne trouve pas d'accord avec
bruxelles
si le parlement rejette un accord
conservateurs ou si le gouvernement ne
parvient à aucun accord nous ferons
pression pour des élections générales
sans quoi toutes les options sont sur la
table et même un nouveau référendum
jeremy corbyn a dû se ranger à la
majorité de son parti
[Applaudissements]
jude kirton darling a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonjour je vous être eurodéputé
britannique du groupe socialiste et
démocrate vous êtes aussi membre du
parti travailliste
alors franchement est ce que vous croyez
à la possibilité d'un nouveau référendum
est ce que cette idée n'ajoute pas de la
confusion je crois que y'a pleins
confusion ne pas craindre la question
petit actuelle mais le réalité c'est
qu'on est complètement 1 impasse au
parlement national et il n'y a pas de
majorité pour les plantes de tueries
mais il n'ya pas majorité pour rester en
europe à travers le député national il
n'y a pas à maturité pour quitter le
groupe sans accord
donc dans cette situation d'impasse le
seule possibilité c'est vous demande le
peuple
qu'est ce que eux ils ont envie de deux
années après les premières frappes qui
est qu'est ce que sont les avis la
situation actuelle et qu'est ce que eux
ils vont ils veulent donne l'avenir
degrés pour moi la possibilité d'un
nouveau référendum un pipeau ce 20 août
ça augmente ce jour après jour avec la
division eau celle de le gouvernement
les divisions au sein de leurs pratiques
comme sa victime alors le plan de
theresa may a été rejetée par les
européens il est contesté dans son parti
mais vu la pression des briques sitter
des ceux qui veulent en divorce dur avec
l'union européenne est ce que le plomb
de theresa may n'est pas un moindre mal
selon vous nous sépare c'est pas le cas
c'est pas la seule alternative crise
mais veut présenter une des pâtures ebit
pas l'air comme ça soit avec moi au
s'élève à l'aise c'est vous voulez il y
a plein d entraîner tva les possibilités
quand on peut avoir un vote avec la
possibilité de rester en europe de john
le vote
et là on investit dans l'avenir il ya
deux possibilités il ya aussi la
possibilité que on avait une élection
nationale le parti travailliste prom pu
voir et on a essayé de négocier un
accord qui serait un peu
comme la corne de norvège et l'union
européenne pour l'avenir il ya beaucoup
de possibilités l'idée que c'est le
proposition de tourisme et aux arbres
exact ça c'est complètement faux débat
que crise mais c'est de plus avoir le
support son accord et voulait travailler
qu'est ce que vous souhaiteriez comme
accor nous on aimerait bien le plus pas
plus proches relations avec l'europe
dont l'avenir on reconnaît que le marché
unique
c'est marché qui est très important pour
nos exportateurs pour nous et je suis
pour tu les chaînes de valeur on ne peut
pas nous vtv d'un mariage de 40 ans
population comme canada avec l'union
européenne ce et c'est pas possible pour
notre économie pour notre société et
donc nous on aimerait bien si on est
entre deux parties de l'europe que leur
relation est le plus proche passé une
union douanière et una corse le marché
unique
theresa may un peu durci son discours
ces derniers jours hier matin elle a
annoncé que pour janvier 2021
l'immigration serait serait resserré les
immigrés ne serait autorisé à rentrer au
royaume uni que selon leur niveau de
qualification et que les européens ne
seront plus favorisés qu'en pensez vous
mais moi je crois que l'autre côté de la
proposition de l'événement les
migrations
c'est que le gouvernement par la
première fois et est en train de couper
le doigt de britannique a travaillé à
voyager étudier dans les autres pays
européens
ça c'est vraiment une catastrophe pour
beaucoup de jeunes en grande bretagne et
s'écouter de les débats mais immigration
et jamais départi par le parti
conservative le parti conservateur est
obsédé par les chiffres
obsédé par cette question des migrations
mais y'a jamais de base qu'est ce que
nous avons besoin comme pays
on a besoin que les gens viennent pour
travailler chez nous ça c'est clair on a
besoin que les gens travaillent pas
seulement dans les qualifications très
haut mais aussi dans les qualifications
qui sont bas dans les métiers qu'ils
sont
mais qui sont moins qualifiés mais cette
barre on n'a pas débattu et a doubt un
grand b trappe à l'émigration et reese
mais n'a créé par là pour avoir cette
barre dernière question les négociations
sont donc très mal partis avec l'union
européenne
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
arriver à aucun accord il ya toujours
une possibilité pas exempt au palais pas
un choix
il ya certains dans notre parti
conservateur jay crise morgue et d'autre
que veut vraiment quand on pas de
l'union européenne
son accord il veut créer le quéau un pas
au pot fait l'agent tonique et on doit
complètement franchi il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont fait beaucoup d'argent
après le référendum en donnait le pari
contraire notre pays mais aussi paul
c'est un projet beaucoup plus long terme
pour créer le chaos pour que le projet
européenne se fonde en europe aussi pour
créer une premier domino pour pousser
que le projet européenne et tu l'union
européenne se fondent dans les années à
venir et ça il faut tu fais tu pour
qu'ils
il veille aussi pas merci beaucoup
madame kirton darling d'avoir été à nos
côtés aujourd'hui tout autre sujet
maintenant le prélèvement à la source de
l'impôt sur le revenu la france y passe
au 1er janvier prochain alors que la
plupart des pays européens fonctionnent
comme cela depuis à des décennies
l'espagne depuis 1979
alors comment ça marche les salariés les
entreprises en sont ils satisfaits
regardez ce reportage de françois goujon
à madrid
la france est à la traîne en europe
voilà quarante ans que l'espagne prélève
ses impôts à la source les 19 millions
et demi de contribuables espagnols sont
directement ponctionnés sur leurs
salaires sur la fiche de paye de carlos
flores ses 24 % de son salaire en moins
qui passe presque inaperçue enfin juste
une seule ligne et qui s'appelle t
votation rpf qui correspond au
prélèvement à la source des impôts donc
à la fin c'est beaucoup plus clair parce
que tu as et une seule ligne et après tu
en est qui est vraiment d'une étape
carlos flores et français ce commercial
au salaire très variable selon les mois
s'est installé à madrid il ya cinq ans
il a subi de plein fouet le décalage
d'un an du système français
l'activité en france l'année précédente
j'ai dû payer la même année deux types
d'impôts pour la france et pour
l'espagne moi je préfère l'espagne juste
un espagnol en france moi j'étais
mensualités et a toujours un décalage vu
que mon variable pèse beaucoup sur mon
salaire global donc il faut faire
toujours des ajustements il faut faire
des calculs
pratiquement tous les ans par contre en
espagne c'est quelque chose de fixe et a
pas de calcul à faire à cette plus clair
ce sont donc les entreprises qui
collectent l'argent pour l'état comme
dans cette pme madrilène air coatex où
l'on fabrique les uniformes de la garde
royale
aulas la société est dirigée par un
autre français jonathan vierne
faites un effort pour connaître le taux
d'imposition que chacun doit payer les
employés transmettent à leurs patrons
des informations personnelles pouvant
conduire à des abattements mariage
nombre d'enfants handicap ou conjointe
au chômage l'employeur fait donc tout le
travail à la place de l'état
l'entreprise a trois casquettes la
première c'est cette fameuse déclaration
est de l'association familiale qu'elle
instruise doit faire remplir à tous ses
employés après il faut faire les
feuilles de paye donc chaque feuille de
paye c'est un impôt différent une fois
que c'est fait il faut reverser cet
argent au trésor public
non alors au final c'est vrai que si
l'entreprise n'a pas eu non mon cabinet
comptable en expert comptable c'est
l'entreprise qui a cette charge ce
travail administratif à faire un plus
pour être coté ex et ses 28 salariés
aucun problème
les comptables se charge de
l'administratif mais pour les petites
entreprises
ce sont de nombreuses heures perdues
passé devant l'ordinateur pour ce
travailleur indépendant
se pose également une question morale la
responsabilisation des citoyens
je pense que le travailleur devrait
recevoir son salaire brut et déclaré lui
même la partie qui doit donner à l'état
comme ça au bout d'un jean se rendrait
compte de ce que coûte le fruit de leur
travail
je serais plus juste pour tout le monde
l'employeur et le travailleur totalement
informatisé l'impôt à la source
fonctionne plutôt bien en espagne malgré
un gros raté en 2006 où 500 millions
d'euros ont été trop perçus par l'état
depuis l'administration a rectifié le
tir
le ministère des finances se veut
rassurant aujourd'hui c'est l'état qui
est débiteur en même temps une salle
donnait aujourd'hui le solde pour 2010
cette aide est favorable à
l'administration fiscale
c'est à dire qu'il y a plus d'argent a
demandé au contribuable qu'à leur rendre
je pense que c'est un système efficace
gestion administrative ont évidemment en
terme de temps mais les automatismes et
l'informatique nous permettent d'avoir
une gestion raisonnablement efficace
quant aux données personnelles
auxquelles ont accès les employeurs
après quelques polémiques dans la
péninsule le procédé semble être
globalement acceptée les citoyens
peuvent désormais s'ils le veulent
transmettre leur situation familiale
directement au ministère
[Musique]
et pour parler du prélèvement à la
source chaque oeil sur ce plateau jean
arthuis bonjour bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputés français de l'alliance
démocrates et des libéraux pour l'europe
à vos côtés et mercedes bresso bonjour
je vous êtes heureux députés italienne
du groupe socialiste et démocrate alors
on a vu l'exemple en espagne vous
l'italie vous appliquez le prélèvement à
la source depuis plusieurs décennies
est-ce que ça se passe bien oui ça se
passe bien
finalement on a réduit l'évasion fiscale
la petite asia fiscale qui se faisait
quand même et ce tous les citoyens sont
contents parce que n'ont pas
l'impression de payer des impôts
par contre c'est clair que avec le temps
qui passe
on a l'impression qu'on paye pas
d'impôts parce qu'on oublie la partie en
peau de son revenu et donc on a
l'impression d'être payés moins nous
très souvent les gens disent je gagne
temps et 10 le net ce qu'ils voient dans
la fiche de paye à réalité le revenu le
plus élevé mais il ya la retenue à la
source qu'ils oublient donc ça disons
10.10 de la responsabilité fiscale sa
baisse un peu la responsabilité fiscale
par contre c'est très pratique parce que
ça réduit énormément les charge
bureaucratique pour un citoyen si vous
avez des petits revenus des droits
d'auteur des petites activités
il ya aussi la retenue à la source donc
à la fin vous rajouter ça mais c'est
très facile à faire le calcul est de
nouveau vous avez presque rien payer
parce que tout est revenu à la source
aussi dans les activités occasionnelles
pourquoi est-ce que cela a permis de
réduire l'évasion fiscale explique ému
parce que tout citoyen disons-le
italiens aic a même un pays dans lequel
l'évasion fiscale est très élevé comme
vous savez donc dans la gestion des
déductions possibles
parfois on en faisait des calculs mal
fait on entendait des bons je me trompe
un peu comme ça je paye un peu moins
puis éventuellement on compte sur le
fait que sira revenu moyen ou bas
l'état ne va pas faire de contrôle
évidemment cancer est de nyala
tous ces contrôles sont faits et les
calculs sont faits correctement
donc je de ce point de vue ça réduit la
petite évasion fiscale pas évidemment la
grande bascule et les grandes fortunes
ne sont pas même si même si ray les
actions par exemple les titres et c'est
à la réunion à la sauce ce fait c'est
toujours monsieur ensuite pourquoi la
france est à la traîne pourquoi nous
sommes les casinos les derniers en
europe à mettre en place ce prélèvement
à la source
ça fait 40 ans qu'on en parle et si on
attends tu hésites et c'est parce que
nous avons un barème d'impôt sur le
revenu des personnes physiques qui est
très particulier et assez complexes
d'abord il est familiale cela veut dire
qu'on rassemble les revenus des deux
conjoints éventuellement des enfants
ensuite le barème est progressif il ya
un quotient familial va tenir compte du
nombre d'enfants l'italie s'est produit
non on a des discussions pour les
enfants c'est différent c'est le maremne
et individuelles monde le barème est
individualisé et lorsqu'il est
individuel c'est automatique
je ne pose pas de problème c'est ce que
nous faisons en france avec la csg c'est
un taux fixe il est il est perçu sur les
revenus individuels mais mais nous avons
en plus des niches fiscales des
déductions des abattements des
réductions des crédits d'impôts bon
voilà qui compliquait la tâche
et voilà pourquoi on a mis autant de
temps donc opté pour leur retenue à la
source imposerait en préalable d'aller
vers une imposition par individu ce qui
n'est pas l'option qui a été prise en
france
bon cela étant ça ne dispensera pas
d'ailleurs de faire chaque année une
déclaration d'impôt sur le revenu des
personnes physiques pour rassembler
précisément l'ensemble des revenus de
calculer l'impôt qui est dû et de
comparer les prélèvements qui ont été
exercées et l'impôt qui est du si on
associe les prélèvements sont supérieurs
à ce que l'on doit effectivement
l'état remboursera la différence si en
revanche c'est inférieur et bien le
foyer fiscal devra payer un complément
d'impôt alors il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétudes chez les contribuables
chez les employeurs aussi sur d
éventuels bugs est-ce que vous en italie
il ya eu des bugs non écoutez je crois
qu'effectivement le système français est
un peu plus complexe mais une fois mis
en place vous allez déclaré quels sont
les revenus de la famille et donc que le
barème auquel vous êtes soumis et puis
le l'employeur a fait sur chaque
employeur des deux conjoints
c'est le prélèvement c'est clair que
s'il ya des modifications sensibles
il faut le communiqué à son employeur
autrement de toute façon tous ceux qui
ont de revenir complexe
même en italie sont obligés de faire une
déclaration maintenant l'état essaie de
leur envoyer une déclaration pré
calculées sur la base de tous les rêves
ni dont il est à connaissance donc avec
le temps on arrivera à améliorer aussi
le système mais je crois que finalement
on trouve des solutions parce que les
seuils les revenus ne change pas
beaucoup d'une année à l'autre les
déductions fiscales peuvent être
communiquées donc elles sont faites par
l'employeur c'est que l'employeur a une
petite charge en plus mais le sont
employés par contre ils se sentent plus
tranquille parce que les gens semblent
sont très agités quand ils font la
déclaration de revenus il essaye de la
faire eux mêmes pour ne pas payer un
corner fiscaliste mais après ils ont
très peur de s'être trompé les honnêtes
on perd donc je pâques ça ça soulage
beaucoup le citoyen moyen circuit est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un risque politique est
un risque politique pour le gouvernement
imposer ce prélèvement à la source parce
que les gens ont 1er janvier vous voir
leur bulletin de salaire le montant de
leur fiche de paye diminué évidemment
mais beaucoup de contribuables avaient
opté pour la mensualisation de l'impôt
mais c'est à dire que à quoi à
prélèvement était exercée sur leur
compte personnel
donc je crois qu'il n'a pas vraiment de
différence j'ai la conviction que les
services du ministère de l'économie et
des finances ont mis au point le
dispositif naturellement c'est une
charge supplémentaire pour les
employeurs ouais ça c'est incontestable
une complication qu'on leur impose dont
il se serait volontiers dispensés
probablement mais je crois que ça
devrait se passer bien les cas
particuliers n'entreront pas dans ce
système parce que il faudra les traiter
comme tel bon c'est sans doute au plan
pratique une commodité qui est offerte
j'ajoute que on a quand même maintenant
un système de déclaration par internet
l'administration communique aux
contribuables des déclarations pré
imprimés la simplicité sur les travaux
considérables ont été accomplis par
l'administration fiscale
c'est incontestablement un progrès je
pense que ce serait de bonne politique
de réduire toutes ces niches fiscales
tous et ses déductions régulation
abattement qui fait qu'on n'y comprend
plus rien sauf à a donné une rente de
situation aux conseillers fiscaux
alors on reste dans les questions
budgétaires et monétaires avec un
nouveau défi qui s'ouvre pour l'europe
l'italie gouvernée par le mouvement 5
étoiles et la ligue vient d'annoncer un
budget de relance bien loin des critères
de bruxelles qui laisse filer les
déficits
la commission européenne exhorte
l'italie à revoir sa copie rome accusent
bruxelles de terrorisme sur les marchés
financiers écoutez la réponse de pierre
moscovici le commissaire européen à
l'économie commissaire européen je suis
là pour faire
respecter une règle qui est une règle
commune qu'il y du bon sens qui est la
règle qui permet de limiter la
progression de la dette et qui permet
aussi de s'assurer que nos finances
publiques sont gérées de manière saine
dans l'intérêt de nos concitoyens parce
qu'encore une fois qu'on me fait des
dépenses publiques à la fin et bien
quelqu'un dit les payes et l'idée qu'il
y ait d'un côté et de l'autre côté les
règles bureaucratiques européenne ne
tient pas la route
mercedes bresso vous êtes italienne
est-ce que ce budget est une provocation
ou un vrai plan de relance avec des
bonnes choses pour les italiens écoutez
c'est d'abord ça n'existe pas on sait
qu'ils ont décidé d'atteindre 2,4 pour
cent de déficit
à part ça et même pas eu ils ne
connaissent pas les chiffres réels qui
sont derrière le document de l'économie
et finances ils sont en train de les
écrire peut-être que ce matin ou demain
matin on les connaîtra donc pour juger
il faut connaître et à mon avis même en
arrivant à 2 4% ils ne pourront pas
faire toutes les choses qu'il ils ont
déclaré vont faire avec ça surtout parce
que ce n'est pas de la faute ni au caire
ni à moscovici la faute c'est à ceux qui
déclarent que ce serait mieux de sortir
de l'euro que de toute façon on peut
aller de l'avant avec un déficit peut
être que appelé déficits dettes parce
que l'italie à une dette énorme donc
elle doit à réduire commencer à réduire
sa dette pour réduire la dette il faut
réduire la nouvelle dette de chaque
année c'est à dire le déficit n'y a
aucune autre manière de le dire la dette
donc 120 arrière très fortement parce
qu'on était arrivé à 0 8% donc la dette
compte tenu de l'inflation commençait à
se réduire et on avait des taux
d'intérêt très bas l'a déjà avec les
déclarations qu'ils ont faites pas
seulement le fait de dire 2,4 ont pas de
0,8 à 2,4 donc on va re augmenter la
dette mais ils ont déclaré des choses
contre l'euro qui qui ne font que se
retourner contre l'italie parce que
c'est évident que les investisseurs
si ces lieux les investisseurs
institutionnels à ce moment là ont peur
et donc ils se bloquent
ils attendent de savoir exactement ce
qui se passe jusqu'à maintenant le
gouvernement italien aurait avantage à
se taire a présenté clairement les
chiffres et après commencer une
négociation avec l'union européenne
s'ils ont besoin d'un peu de flexibilité
en plus je vois que moscovici avait déjà
dit qu'il était disponible mais je crois
qu'il faut parler peu et faire les
comptes correctement et dire exactement
ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils réduisent et à
la fin quel est le sol de réelles et pas
celui victime monsieur arthur vous êtes
inquiet avec cette proposition du jazz
italien
j'écoute mercedes bresso les évaluations
de dépenses sont elles fondées ou pas et
là j'aimerais que la commission exerce
son pouvoir de surveillance on parle
souvent de bruxelles comme le père
fouettard moi j'observe que le père
fouettard n'a jamais souhaité non à la
grèce quand même non non il n'y a pas eu
de sanctions
c'est qu'à un moment la grèce était en
cessation de paiement et là où on est
bien à juste à l'égard de l'euro c'est
que s'il n'y avait pas l'euro
je pense que le gouvernement italien
aujourd'hui aurait bien du mal à
emprunter sur les marchés
il travaillait pelé c'est parce qu'il ya
l'euro qu'une sorte de mutualisation
s'est opérée et qu'on inspire la
confiance au marché néanmoins en dépit
de cette confiance soliveres général des
prêteurs pense toujours que s'il y avait
cessation de paiement on ne laisserait
pas tomber l'italie c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec la grèce est néanmoins
aujourd'hui lorsque l'italie va sur le
marché il ya 300 points de base
supplémentaires ça veut dire que les
taux d'intérêt augmentent de 3% alors
très brièvement est ce que vous estimez
vous qu'il faut des sanctions contre
l'italie sanctions jeux je n'y crois pas
ce qui manque à la zone euro c'est un
vrai gouvernement économique financier
et budgétaire ce qui manque à la zone
euro c'est un
budget cet amour épaules et nous avons
une zone euro avec une politique
monétaire mais nous n'avons pas de
politique économique européenne nous
avons une relation de politique
nationale
donc cette situation ne peut pas d'avs
et l'urgence c'est de consolider la zone
euro et lui donner un vrai gouvernement
on a bien compris les enjeux et vous
savez a vraiment c est important parce
que si vous pouvez recevoir aussi des
aides évidemment vous êtes plus incités
à la discipline fiscale
on a bien compris merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous sur ce plateau merci à
vous nous avoir suivis rendez-vous à la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
d' europe hebdo
[Musique]